as we documented last night the student
walkout for gun control yesterday looked
at times more like a political
celebration than a somber protest with
left-wing politicians greeted like
rockstars
look at how the crowd gathered at the US
Capitol with their selfie sticks in hand
greeted Bernie Sanders as he made his
way to the bullhorn oh my god they were
going nuts it was pure partisan politics
it was scripted and screamed and why am
I saying that because because it's not
simply about the draw anymore because
it's not simply about gun control this
is about human life this is about the
children who have lost their lives to
gun violence so I asked our Republican
lawmakers is their right to have a gun
more important than our right to live
not partisan at all look that's a nice
applause line but of course the wrath of
the students is misdirected the lines
are shouting many use repeatedly over
the years by anti-gun activist
conveniently do not address the real
problem with that horrific tragedy at
Stoneman Douglas high the NRA is not
responsible for allowing Nicholas Cruz
to be armed and dangerous neither are
Republican politicians that young lady
just called out who supports Second
Amendment rights for law-abiding
Americans
a new surveillance video just released
by court order confirms what we already
knew due to malfeasance cowardice or
just pure poor judgment the first
officer on the scene
Broward deputy Scott Peterson did not
enter building 1200 where Cruz was
carrying out his slaughter he arrives on
a golf cart you see him there with staff
members while the massacre was underway
in the video shows Peterson with his gun
drawn
but then he steps back and he remains
outside and he stood there as Nicolas
Cruz's six-minute spree of shooting
continued well in a statement Peterson's
lawyer claimed the deputy thought the
shots were being fired outside but these
radio communications released last week
demonstrate that he knew the shots were
coming from inside building 12 as we'll
discuss in a moment
Peterson and none of the other three
officers that were on the scene followed
police protocol remember what Broward
sheriff Scott Israel that number said
when he was pressed about Peterson's
response I gave him a gun I gave him a
badge I gave him the training if he
didn't have the heart to go in that's
not my responsibility no so much for the
buck stopping at the top Israel I know
it sounds it sounds tough here but he
comes off as a slimy self-promoter and
the stories over the years about how
he's hired his friends and his family in
key positions reportedly many of them
not qualified after he was elected and
this is the same guy
by the way sheriff Israel who thought it
was appropriate to opine on a CNN Town
Hall just a week after the shooting they
were supposed to be doing the
investigation he's on TV and of course
when he was on TV he did not even
mention the failure of Scott Peterson on
scene look many of those advocating for
gun control post parkland they want to
look away from the errors committed by
law enforcement which were numerous and
frankly obscene at both the federal and
the state level there's almost no
discussion at yesterday's rallies
mentioning the fact that Nicholas Cruz's
dangerous and disturbing behavior was
flagged repeatedly to authorities over a
period of
years starting in February of 2016 now
just a few reminders because we forget
this stuff after just a month on
February 5th 2016 Broward Police is told
by an anonymous caller that Nicholas
Cruz had threatened to shoot up his
school and posted a photo of himself
with guns on Instagram the info was
provided to deputy Scott Peterson then
on September 28th 2016 an investigator
for the Florida Department of Children
and Families concludes after a visit
that Cruz is stable despite finding
fresh cuts on his arms apparently
self-inflicted his mother Linda Cruz
said he had recently spoken of buying
weapons then on September 24th 2017 a
YouTube user named Nicholas Cruz posts a
comment stating he wants to become quote
a professional school shooter the FBI
and Mississippi hears of this but fails
to make the connection to Florida then
there was this a few weeks after his
mother died on November 29 2017 the Palm
Beach County family that took Cruz in
after his mother's death called the Palm
Beach Sheriff's Office to report a fight
between Cruz and their son
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cheated on himself but he has real guns
are going to get now then she mentions
specific threats he had made some leave
all to hear this and then there were two
other calls one to Broward the next day
and one to the FBI on January 5th of
this year
tagging Cruz again as a potential school
shooter
neither Broward nor the FBI followed up
so well everybody's denouncing the NRA
or trashing President Trump in the wake
of the sickening school shooting
activists might think that although it's
fun to get the coverage on the evening
news or you know be the subject of an
exciting viral video for your speech in
front of the Capitol you're only hurting
your own cause if you refuse to
acknowledge really focus on the fact
that we actually didn't need new laws to
stop Cruz we needed to follow the proper
policing on the state and federal levels
because had those that policy those
protocols actually been conducted Cruz
would have been prevented from carrying
out the Parkland carnage he probably
wouldn't have been able to get a gun in
the first place sheriff Scott Israel
after all of this look he should have
packed his desk as soon has he learned
of deputy Peterson's failure on his
watch the shooter was not confronted in
the building instead of passing the buck
and grandstanding against the NRA that's
what a good sheriff would have done and
that's the angle